I have learned so much about Texas that
now I know this state I believe like the
back of my hand I really do I think I'm
an expert on Texas you sound pretty
cocky for somebody who's only been there
a couple of days I am serious I'm not
being cocky I'm being serious nobody at
this point knows Texas better than I do
I don't think it's possible well then
you should have no problem passing the
just invented Texas citizenship test
here to administer the test
please welcome 12-time NBA all-star from
your very own Dallas Mavericks
Dirk Nowitzki
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you very much
great to be here thank you very much
Conan you talk a good game and now it's
time to answer questions about this
great state from a true Texan I'm ready
let's do it here we go all right here we
go
what is the state nickname of Texas the
Lone Star State who is the current
governor of Texas Rick Perry
the city of Dallas was founded by home.i
jr ewing named the largest dome in texas
dr. Phil what is the leading cause of
heart attacks in Texas Tony Romo
what's over yonder everything that's not
under yonder which too far countries
does Texas border Mexico and the United
States name a progressive children's
book based in Texas the queer steer
named Amir
[Applause]
what is my NBA nickname your NBA
nickname is the dunking weitzman correct
I would have also accepted these months
Dirk Diggler the German wunderkind the
germinator the 7-foot schnitzel the
Berlin tall super strudel baron phone
slamming Stein Admiral from slamming
Heusen Kaiser found Duncan stop there
Duncan schnitzel there dribble Meister
on there Duncan mice very nice
onto the test all right what is the
state bird of Texas beef what is the
state flower of Texas see on what day
did Texas become a US state beats ember
20 beef 18 BTB the stars at night are
big and bright
[Applause]
who carries my stuff Beaver Dam and the
earth village Africa's little an bit
soggy Vardhan Dimitri for Disney sea
otters from AT&T Stadium name is the
Dallas Area Rapid Transit is like to
know
and centralization unique tune out to
Allen name insightly Seiken seein
Collins after Andrews case Isaac
laughs ladies a stadium
I don't know what you just said all
right for the next round I'm gonna show
you a series of photos and you have to
tell me whatever the person in each
photo is a Dallas Cowboy a Texas Ranger
a usin rocket the Santoni spur or a
Dallas Maverick here we go
okay that's 20 Romo cowboy okay
that's you maverick that's John Wayne
he's a cowboy that's an actual spur
that's Prince Fielder who's a Texas
Ranger but he's dressed like a New York
Ranger okay that's a real rocket dressed
as a Dallas Cowboy
okay that's Walker Texas Ranger kicking
all right that's maverick from Top Gun
riding on the back of a Kimo lies one
who's a Houston rocket from the waist up
in an actual rocket from the waist down
okay that's Texas Ranger Yu Darvish
dressed like a real cowboy riding a
horse that for some reason has San
Antonio spur Tim Duncan's head and he's
not selling thallus cowboy Troy Aikman
who's dressed like a spur the whole
thing is being photo blind by Houston
rocket James Harden whose beard is
wearing at Texas Rangers Jersey
[Applause]